what I just want to watch you go to the
bathroom don't be such a bigot jeez
jacked oh my God as someone who's out to
make the world a better place one of my
passions in life is being in whatever
restroom I want when I want like it's
just common sense for inclusivity right
like you're going tinkle so let's
include me in that process it's my right
I think privacy is the enemy of
inclusivity something I try to teach
kids while I'm dancing that'll help them
throughout their whole lives is tampons
should be in all restrooms because
everybody needs tampons oh my god oh
yeah this is a real now just just in
case you guys don't know this is a guy
named JP Sears he's a comedian and a
commentator social and political
commentator wait you mean he's not
really trans he's obviously parodying
yes I know come on trans people right
now but everything he's saying are real
things that trans people are saying
they're out there saying that we need
tampons in men's rooms we do and that
you can be able to go in any bathroom
you want and it's fine it's not fine I
don't want to do food in the ladies room
and you know what no women aren't
standing up for themselves men need to
stand up for us no it's disgusting if I
ever saw a dude going to bed in the
woman's room it's on site gee if I think
that I don't want a dude like a
biological dude in the bathroom with my
mother who couldn't protect herself
against a biological dude no offense but
you have little chicken arms I do every
time you try to hit me it's like
grabbing Chopsticks I don't want any
dude oh my God I could snap it I don't
want any dude in there with you I have
nieces I don't want anyone in there with
them other than other girls it's
disgusting to think about when when
growing up did you ever what you used to
bring me into like the women's bathroom
when I was little right is it weird for
guys to bring girls in the men's
bathroom if you're their dad or it's not
it's like huh is it a different dynamic
because I don't really remember well I'm
not a girl but I I don't really see
girls going into the men's room like
little girls like ever it's always right
like let's say it's like let's let's
pick an age like five because I if you
were five I still bring you in the
ladies room we go into the start we have
stalls in the ladies room in a men's
room there's urinals so five-year-old
girl can is fully cognizant of her
surroundings so maybe when I was growing
up it wasn't a thing like I didn't go in
the men's room ever my dad would send me
if I if I was somewhere with my dad he'd
send you another woman he'd send me in
the women's room and wait for you wait
outside yeah that makes sense and when I
was like in diapers and two or two years
old I wasn't without my mom my dad
didn't take me places maybe you took me
for ice cream and straight back home you
know because we just yeah you went with
your mom moms were were around equal
tampon rights is a cause I am firmly
dedicated to and you know what I'm sorry
if I'm making too big of a difference in
the world for you I stopped Eva for two
reasons one Matt Walsh eats meat so it's
and two because I couldn't get anything
weird that means natural dude and two
meat isn't labeled with the identified
gender of the animals so I really don't
know what I'm putting into my body and
third it is wrong to brutally cut into
an animal's flesh it is inhumane
these are the leftovers for my surgery I
always keep them with me I've actually
started an initiative to force the USDA
to label all foods with the preferred
pronouns of the food it's just basic
nutritional information that should be
on the label but in the meantime please
boycott all food you should check out my
Tick Tock I do a lot of inspirational
posts you have no idea how offensive
Aretha Franklin's song Natural Woman is
to me as a proud neurodivergent
non-racially identified non-biological
anorexia plus woman I'm in the position
to say this black woman should have no
right to sing a song about what it is to
be a natural woman she's clearly spewing
hate towards me with a song She Wrote
before I was born and you know what I'm
just as natural of a woman as any other
woman the large amount of hormones that
I take on a daily basis at the start of
the trans [__] it wasn't even like them
trying to convince us that it's real
women right wasn't it just like let them
dress as women yeah
already doing that's the thing there
wasn't a problem yeah you were letting
them but now the fact that you're
genuinely trying to change the way that
the world Works where you're saying men
can be women when you destroy objective
reality you open the mind to Ultimate
slave programming I truly believe that
that's all that this is that's exactly
you convince people that men can be
women women can be men what can you not
convince them of what can you not
convince okay racism we had very small
amount of racism in this country okay
they came out about you know during the
Obama Administration and it just all
everything became about racism and then
it became all about BLM and protests and
burning things down and race Racers race
okay we didn't have a problem they made
a problem we didn't have a problem with
transgender people either you saw them
you see them you say that there was
widespread transgender hate is a [__]
lie okay if anything they're making
themselves get hated more by doing all
this [__] right but then they wanted to
go from being a fringe some somebody
somebody somewhere because they because
they were fine just living their lives
it's an attention somebody wanted to
grow that population and so they started
going after kids they found the kids in
their phones lonely in their rooms this
all got crazy during covid and they went
in there and the kids were depressed
because they weren't socializing they
were locked in their houses many of them
in Dysfunctional homes think about the
pronouns thing and you know pronouns how
you like they all the social media
within the last two years they added it
so you should add your pronouns what's
the point of that the only point of that
is to make them feel more included
that's all it is right I'm saying it's
not it's not an inclusion she used to
feel to feel like they belong somewhere
because being a teenager is weird and
it's awkward puberty sucks but there's
obvious girls and obvious boys putting
she her and he him in your bio yeah why
that's to make that's to be an ally an
ally
that's how it's that's how it started to
be explained blamed it's to be an ally
because because somebody that is trans
isn't obviously you know is it's just
playing into the delusion it's playing
into the delusion that's all it is
I'm gonna play with you I'm gonna
pretend with you so even though I'm a
she her I'm gonna put make sure
everybody writes I write it down for
everybody so that you don't feel as as
bad about yourself that you have to put
she her pronouns which you don't have to
you never did you receive in a dress and
you wanted to call yourself Sheila fine
nobody no I have to but now I have to
put my pronouns in my at schools now you
if you're in the zoom you gotta put your
[__] pronouns next to your name you
gotta introduce yourself with your
pronouns what do I look like pronouns
it's so stupid but they went after the
kids and that's why so now they'll say
that I'm a hater I hate trans people I
don't hate trans people I actually feel
sorry for the legitimate small
percentage of the population that has
gender dysphoria I feel really sorry for
them because they are being dragged into
this thing where we're now getting them
to we're basically what all they've done
is create a big [__] business it's
just billions of dollars being spent on
hormone therapy and gender mutual and
mutilation surgery that's what this is
that's what this is that's crazy it's a
business and they came after the kids
and they can all go to hell basis that
my body doesn't naturally produce makes
me a natural woman like everybody's a
natural woman and to think otherwise is
just to be disconnected from facts and
it's pure hate I will not be on Spotify
until they ban all of Aretha Franklin's
music take that Spotify I had a free
account because you know the funny thing
about like the Bud Light [__] too where
um most of them are a lot of Americans
that are against this [__] they stopped
buying the Bud Light things and then the
Liberals were like I thought you guys
were against cancer culture not cancel
culture exactly I was just about to say
this it's not cancer culture we're not
saying to take bloodline out of stores
and to not make it illegal to sell it
we're saying to stop buying it big
difference so cancel if you wanted to
cancel cancel culture Andrew Tate all
this all this [__] that with that same
logic would be just don't watch him
instead of trying to shut him down right
cancel culture is permanent is silencing
and trying to permanently erase someone
because they said something or did
something I don't think Bud Light should
be banned I just think that if you are
against all the [__] that's going on and
you want to make an example of somebody
yeah stop buying their stuff let them
take a little hit and guess what they
got a new they got a new marketing lead
yeah I I I my thing is you want to play
this game Bud Light that's fine you can
play I'm I'm leaving the table I'm not
sitting at this table with you and I
never once said or even really heard
anybody say that marketing executive
should be fired no one even said that no
one said that no it's like all right
stop buying it so that's the thing when
they're like oh you so now you like
cancel culture I'm like you're not even
making sense you clowns I don't mind the
ads and they're not gonna get my
business back of providing me with a
free account until they meet my List of
Demands which includes putting tampons
and ketchup in all public and private
restrooms
I'm waiting Spotify I like to swim I'm
pretty good I've been trying to get
pregnant for the past year I really want
to bring a child into this world and
raise they the right way could you
imagine doing a natural home birth
vaginal delivery and throwing a
beautiful gender reveal party when they
is 15 years old but I'm running into
some complications in the conception
process you know sperm isn't as strong
as it once was with all the toxic
masculinity that's in our water nowadays
so I started the in vitro fertilization
process and so far not working because
apparently I don't have very good
doctors they
up with the women also they're like you
can get pregnant from bone marrow that
was another one of their points you can
get you don't need man you get pregnant
from bone marrow yeah all right we'll
see how kid how smart your kids are your
little Jurassic Park kids little shoes
weirdos
it's like
find any eggs to fertilize well
Khan they gotta be in here somewhere or
just fertilize something else
these bigoted doctors if they can't get
the job done I will be suing for medical
malpractice the crime
hate so as you can tell there's a lot of
adversity in my life and none of it's my
own doing but as a strong Brave person I
will be relentlessly waiting for someone
else to fix my problems for me
and I'm not gonna give up
what's going on in the world just behind
the scenes that that they have us
distracted with all this nonsense like
what crazy [__] is the government up
to that they are actually out here out
here pulling this all right let's wrap
it up make sure to subscribe to my mom's
Channel yeah I'll be putting out a lot
of new YouTube videos this month I'll be
moving to Miami soon so she has to be
doing her own [__] uh follow me on
Instagram at Sunny fast and I'll see you
later
all right
[Music]